All of you are so sweet. And here's a small update
I had to pick up.
She's not allowed to bring her computer and stuff home,
so I had to. Since it's like a long weekend,
I had to go pick it up. So I got to see her today
and I was like, oh,
my god, I'm so sorry that I got the dates wrong.
But I remembered. I was like,
the reason I got the dates wrong
was cause
I remembered that today was the day that the results were coming out.
That's why Friday stuck out in my head.
So that's why I was reaching out to her.
And I do text her every day.
So I did talk to her yesterday.
I just didn't, like,
specifically wish her well on the thing.
And she still has a chance at getting apart.
It was just callbacks so she could still be cast in.
Maybe, like,
a more minor role, I guess. Maybe.
I don't know. But it wasn't the end of the world.
And I did get to give her a big,
like, multiple.